hello everyone and welcome to today's
give go Galaxy tour webinar on genome
editing disease modeling to novel
Therapeutics my name is Michelle Ashton
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Thermo Fisher Scientific for
those of you attending our live session
today the gibco scientists will be
discussing the development of Next
Generation disease models and strategies
for moving crispr-based therapies to the
clinic
you will get to learn about the genome
editing workflow the various Innovations
to improve pluripotent stem cell disease
model construction and the workflow
Solutions which enable clinical and
Commercial scale manufacturing of T-cell
Therapeutics
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our two speakers
for today our first Speaker Dr Eric
Williams
in the cell biology r d senior manager
of Thermo Fisher Scientific
Dr Williams was trained as a stencil
biologist in Brussels Belgium where he
obtained his PhD in 2007. he currently
leads a team in Thermo Fisher Scientific
that focuses on pluripotent stem
cell-based customer driven projects and
product applications including
characterization reprogramming genome
editing differentiation and disease
modeling with a focus on drug Discovery
applications
now in the stem cell field for over 15
years Dr willins published numerous
peer-reviewed articles including in high
impact journals such as stem cell stem
cell
our second speaker Dr Jason Potter is
the r director of genome editing and
Thermo at Thermo Fisher Scientific Dr
Potter leads the genome editing r d
group at Carlsbad California and is
focused on developing and improving
tools for genome editing using the Talon
and crispr Technologies
he has spent 20 years working in biotech
r d and previously LED research focusing
on synthetic genes and the development
of enzymes including superscript 3 and
other reverse transcriptase and
polymerase at Life Technologies let us
welcome Dr Eric Williams Willems to
start his presentation
hi today I will be sharing a little
story around how you can use genome
editing in ipscs to create disease
models to advance your research
so as we all know cell models are
important not just to you know
understand human biology but also in
terms of developing drugs and and
therapies
um to to help mitigate disease so when
you think about human biology there's a
lot of inputs like genetics the
environment nutrition or drugs
and those inputs then result in number
of outputs you know it could be symptoms
or certain biomarkers or the way we feel
and so when you think about modeling
that in an in future situation you kind
of want to try and mimic those inputs so
that you can do some in feature analysis
and and do your biological studies so
when you think about inputs in an in
vitro model we're thinking about
overexpression of knocking enough genes
you have knockdowns or Knockouts you can
use different media systems different
molecules
um and then those changes that are
introduced will then drive alterations
in gene expression protein functions
cellular phenotypes or cell health so
all these things are
you know sort of critical to think from
a human body to an in vitro system and
how you make those transitions in into
the model and so
with the Innovations of pluripotent stem
cells as well as genome editing we have
now a very simple way to generate these
models in vitro so that you can then
generate your disease model of Interest
through pluripotent stem cells you know
these cells can be easily expanded
engineered and differentiated and it's
very scalable for high throughput
screening so you can do a lot with these
cells and then you can bring in genome
editing Technologies using a variety of
different nucleases to knock out
disease-relevant genes to mimic
mutations that are showing up in
patients or you can overexpress disease
relevant genes or correct expression of
disease causing mutations
all all to facilitate disease modeling
in vitro
so when you think about the genome
editing portion
um as most of you probably know you
basically use engineered nucleases to
make changes in the Genome of the cell
and so there are sort of three major
modifications that you can make relevant
to disease so the first one would be a
snip change which you can introduce
using homology driven repair mechanisms
where you know these single snip
mutations oftentimes cause disease in in
patients and you can either correct
those or insert them in a healthy
patient line
and then secondly for disease relevance
there's a gene knockout situation where
you know often mutations lead to
Knockouts of genes or you have full
deletions of genes causing the disease
and so we can mimic that as well using
genome engineering
and then a third approach that's
commonly used is larger Gene insertions
or knock-ins which you know are relevant
in terms of additional copies of genes
that emerge in particular disease as
well
so when you think about using the IPC
model to
generate some disease models you
basically have to think about you know
you have your disease line and then you
have your Healthy line and so you can
think about this two ways in one way you
would take a healthy donor where you
then use the genome editing technology
to introduce a mutation into the genome
to have a disease mimic cell line or you
take a ipsc line from a patient where
you then go in and correct imitation to
a normal situation so that in both cases
you have a pair of ipsc cells that you
can then differentiate for your model so
what I wanted to do today is spend a
little bit of time on how you go about
designing a
disease model pair in ipscs and then
I'll go in a little
um show
case study that we've done there
so first of course is you know how do
you design a genome editing experiment
um evidently the first component that
you use is a nucleus in this case I'm
going to talk about the cas9 nuclei is
very widely used very efficient and the
system
exists in two pieces so you have the
cas9 nucleus which is a protein in many
cases and then you have a guide RNA
which basically targets the cas9 to your
locus of interest and so what we've done
at Thermo Fisher is we developed a
design tool that's available online
scholar true design genome editor
and basically allows you to very simply
design your genome editing experiment
so in in this case we're going to be
looking at the Lark 2 G 2019s snip
change and so what you do is you go into
the true design tool you in this case
you select snip edit but there's also
other editing
um achievements that you can select from
and then
you would click next and in that window
you can then indicate your Gene of
Interest so you can either do that by
selecting the chromosome location
or you can simply choose the gene name
and then the system will populate the
gene information for you with Exon
internal information it will give you
the amino acid sequence of
of your protein as well so it's it's a
very visual representation of the gene
and then
in
you know in that next step then you you
see that when you search for exact
coordinates that the system will take
you to that exact coordinate within your
Gene so that you can then start looking
at making your genetic change and so to
make your genetic changes is very simple
you basically choose through the system
what change you want to make after
you've selected your base that you want
to change so in this case we selected
the G and we want to change that to an a
so you select that in and then basically
the tool recognizes it you click next on
the tool and you know your job is done
and then the tool will work on the
design so in this case you see here that
the tool has identified a guide RNA that
sits very close to the in mutation of
Interest
and then what the tool will do is it'll
identify multiple guide rnas if they are
available and then it will rank them in
a table as you can see here for the one
guide RNA and based on the sequence and
The Binding Affinity of the guide RNA
the different guide rnas will then be
ranked and the ones checked with the
green
check marks such as the one in this
example are then recommended and you can
then order those directly through the
through design platform in addition the
tool will also generate sequences for
the single stranded donor RNA so in case
of a snip change we typically use a
8200 base pair single strand oligo that
carries the mutation that we're changing
and so all these tools are readily
designed
and allow you to order them and get
going on your platform so in terms of
donors and guide our nature design takes
care
of everything for you the next question
then of course is you know I want to use
my cas9 nuclease
um you know what
what form do I use because we have the
the plasmid version available it's an
all-in-one plasmid that both you would
have your guide Ernie and the cas9
expression cassette we then also have
our crispr mRNA and then we have our our
true code cas9 family of proteins
um
you know the the application really is
going to drive this
um the need here in in our case for ipsc
the protein delivery method is the most
efficient for ipsc editing so that is
the one we would choose here
um you know protein has a number of
different advantages in terms of short
half-life direct activity it can be
co-transpected with the guide RNA
um you know it's it's very very
straightforward to work with
to the question then of course becomes
how do we delete
um sorry
um so in terms of the true Cat cast true
cas9 proteins that we have available
we have our standard cas9 protein which
is developed for maximum editing
efficiency we also have our High
Fidelity cas9 protein has a little bit
less of targets compared to the original
true cut protein we're still efficient
on target editing and then recently we
also launched our CTS throughca gas9
protein which is useful for in Vivo and
cell therapy applications
so once you've selected your protein in
this case we will choose the maximum
editing efficiency
um and then you know we'll have to look
at delivery so in terms of delivering to
ipscs there are two main delivery
platforms that work well and you know
the selection of the tool is going to
depending on on your needs and
availability of instruments
um
on the one hand you have a lack of
faction based reagent that can deliver
the rnp complexes as well as DNA or RNA
if interested
um you know it's it's very portable it's
very easy to get to there's good
protocols out there
on the other hand there's the neon elect
preparation system which basically
delivers the rmp through electric
operation it's a lot more efficient
delivery does cause a little bit more
stress on the cells but in general we
find that the near Vector operation
works better for delivery of editing
tools and then that's indicated in this
slide here so in light blue you have the
editing efficiency across a number of
targets
um in in two ipsc lines
for the like effect means stem reagent
and then in dark blue you have that same
result with the neon transfection system
and as you can you can see with the neon
transfectionist system you have
significantly higher editing efficiency
when using the same tools compared to
the lip effector mean stem reagent but
that said in in four of the five targets
that we've looked at there is still
sufficient enough editing going on that
would allow you to successfully isolate
your cell lines of Interest
so knowing this you can then having
those tools selected you can then
leverage our Innovations across the ipsc
portfolio to help building your disease
model so you know that talked about the
genome editing tools we also have a
variety of different media systems and
some matrices specifically designed for
genome editing workflows and then we
also have the differentiation portions
that will help you generate your disease
model and also the instrumentation to do
the phenotyping
so what I wanted to do next is go into a
case study that we've done
um in in terms of taking a healthy ipsc
line and then generating a number of
different disease-causing mutations so
in the example here
um we took a healthy ipsc line and then
introduced a number of snips that are
known to be associated with neuronal as
well as cardiac disease in this slide so
as you can see in terms of homology
driven repair shown by the dark glue
dark blue bars in the middle there
you see that the editing efficiency is
is you know heavily Target dependent but
in in most cases we we do identify a
good number of
um homology driven repair and then
similarly for indels
um we've noted that you know the editing
efficiency so basically just making a
double strand of break in the DNA is is
widely variable from Target to Target
but again at a pretty high efficiency so
then you know of course you you see that
it's it's very challenging to achieve
100 editing and that's where uh in
Imperial potent stem cells you know an
extra cloning step is required to
isolate your cell lines of Interest so
spend some time optimizing single cell
cloning of ipsc using cell sorter
because cell sorters really give you the
highest confidence that you are indeed
depositing single cells into 96 wall
plates
so we did a fairly stringent
um gating strategy here where you know
we do a number of scatter gates to
ensure that we're dealing with single
cells and then in addition we added some
gating around functionality of the cell
so we isolated cells that are expressing
12 and 60 very highly indicative of
pluripotency and then we also read about
the dead cells by sorting out propylene
iodide negative cells and those cells
were then deposited in a number of
different media and substrates to
identify which condition was the best
and you know in in this system we then
found out that using stem flex and
laminin 521 was most efficient for
cloning our ipsc
so when you then sequence all those
clones
um you know not not unexpectedly there
is some correlation between the number
of edited clones that we find and the
overall editing efficiency in the pools
that we've identified and so in as you
can see when we have high editing
efficiency in the pool we have a much
higher incidence of homozygous or
heterozygous snip corrected cell lines
compared to those where the editing
efficiency was lower so in in this case
um you know for the TNN T2
r141w mutation which is a mutation that
causes a cardiac disease we then wanted
to take it further and do some
functional analysis so
basically kind of summarize the model
here is that we we took that clonally
isolated cell line to then Dive Dive
deeper into the dilated cardiomyop
myopathy model and so we we took the
ipsc line and first of course QC that
line to make sure that it is a fully
fully clear potent cell line and then
always compare that with its parental
cell line so as you can see on the
attackman
pluripotency scorecard panel which is a
qpcr based panel we see very similar
readouts in terms of pluripotency and
you know that lack of differentiation
within the culture
um we then furthermore looked at our
plural test assay which is a whole
genome transcriptomic array based
technology to quickly assess the
pluripotency of your ipsc and when your
cell lines land in the Red Cloud which
is represented by over 400 different
ipsc lines you know you can be assured
that your pluripotency is is on on par
with with a normal ipsc line so then
evidently we also check the sequence so
using Next Generation sequencing we
looked at hundred thousands of reads
here and to ensure that the
[Music]
you know invitation was present across
the cell line that there weren't any any
sort of clonal communality issues
um and then you know we we also looked
at the genomic stability using the
kerastodes was sort of a digital
karyotyping
uh approach to show that The genome
editing workflow which is relatively
harsh on the ipscs did not have any
um adverse effects so once we know that
the IPC line was good we then moved on
into differentiation we compared it to
to its parental cell line and as you can
see here
um you know using our cardiomyocyte
differentiation kit we were able to get
cardiomyocytes both from the wild type
as well as the parental cell line and
um you know showing some typical markers
for cardiomyocytes such as troponin 2 in
red and actin in one in green we have
cardiomyocyte formation both in the
parental as well as
disease line and then of course you know
the big question is well do we see any
sort of
phenotypes that could be mimicking what
is happening with the disease in
patients
so you using these derived
cardiomyocytes we then did some
functional analysis
of those cells in in high throughput
settings so basically we used a
fluophour assay which basically is a Dye
that responds to calcium and as
cardiomyocytes contracts spontaneously
calcium is being pumped in and out of
the cell continuously so we can use that
flu 4 measurement as a way to visualize
contraction in cardiomyocytes in a high
throughput setting and so what you can
immediately see when you look at the
calcium transients of the
um control line versus the the mutated
line is that you see that there's a
delay
in
in the peak so the peak is longer
compared to control and then you know
that clearly over time indicates that
those cardiomyocytes are beating slower
compared to their control cell line and
that's shown in the graph on the top
right so there's a slight decrease in
the beat rate of the mutate mutated ipsc
cells
um but more interestingly we then try to
challenge those cardiomyocytes
to see whether we could elicit some
phenotypes or that have been known to be
associated with the disease as well so
using isoproterenol which is a mimic of
the adrenergic receptor so you know
basically mimicking adrenaline
if we treat the cells with that on the
bottom left you see in a DMSO vehicle
control the cells are beating at a
regular pace and then at the white line
there the compound gets dialed in when
you add in DMSO nothing happens to the
beat rate whereas if you add the
isoproterenol you see a rapid increase
of the B trading control cells
interestingly when you look on the right
hand side
at the mutant you see that the
exopreturner challenge
initially increases the beat rate but
then the cardiomyocytes stop beating all
together meaning you know they could not
handle that
um adrenaline stimulation and they just
stop Contracting so this is indicative
of
um similarities with the
actual disease in patients and and this
kind of model can now be used to screen
for further drugs that could
um you know ameliorate these these
issues with isoproterinol for example
so to sort of summarize
um the generation of the disease model
is that you know from a genome editing
point of view we have a number of
Innovations and tools that can help you
um for
for the design of your experiment the
true design editor really enables you to
generate tools quickly and then in
addition you know we have a number of
media and Matrix Systems that really
enable the uh processing of the ipsc
through the genome editing workflow you
know facilitated single cell cloning is
is a key achievement of those media
systems and then we have the tools
available as well too
differentiate to some type of Interest
as well as the analysis of them so when
you think about Thermo Fisher in terms
of the ipsc disease modeling environment
you know we really have the tools and
workflows to do everything going from
taking a donor from a patient you can do
sequence analysis after patient
we can then reprogram them into ipsc we
have the media systems to grow those
ipsc we have the tools to characterize
the ipsc we have all the tools available
to engineer the Genome of the ipsc to
help you mimic your disease and as
mentioned we also have the tools
available
4
differentiation as well as the
instrumentation to do the analysis
and with that I will wrap up my
presentation and thank you for your time
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you Eric for the insightful
session on leveraging genome editing of
ipscs to create disease models next I
would like to invite Jason to share more
about applications of crispr genome
editing Technologies for cell therapy
all right hello I'm Jason Potter I'm a
director at genome engineering here at
Thermo Fisher and today I'm going to be
talking to you about some of the
considerations uh when you're developing
applications for using crispr genome
editing and for cell Therapies
so glad you're all here uh today going
to be talking about the evolution of
crispr moving towards therapeutic
development and then talk through a
couple of genome editing tools uh all
the way from the design of the
experiment through the implementation in
relevant cell types and then talk
through also how do you go from early
research kind of pre-clinical work uh
all the way through clinical
implementation and this we're going to
be using the example of the cas9 rmp
complex and why that's good and uh the
use of GMP reagents
so
to start off with
over the last few years since the Advent
of crispr back about
is about 12 years now
there's been a rapid increase in the use
of crispr and the many applications of
it we're all aware of that but over the
last couple of years what we're starting
to see is clinical application and the
use of this
um is going to be used more and more for
gene therapy we have the early gene
therapy trials that aren't aren't
necessarily using crispr
um but the crispr applications oh I'd
say with intelia crispr Therapeutics and
others are really hitting the mainstream
now and working to the point where we're
starting to see the hope that this will
became a mainstream uh therapeutic use
so that instead of just rare diseases
it'll be applied to
more common diseases and kind of move to
the Cure instead of
everyday treatment
so we see these trials we see different
versions the most common thing that
we've seen is crispr cast 9 and the most
common model that you'll see is the
sickle cell and that's because it's a
pretty understood uh disease and it's
straightforward on what you need to do
to be able to treat it so that has been
the most common model going forward
and
not going to talk too much about that
so
for T-cell engineering which is another
application
um that has been showing a lot of
Promise one of the main re one of the
main ways of going about it now is with
lentivirus uh payloads and these are
used to deliver the car complex so that
you can modify The receptors and Target
the T cells towards your epitope of
Interest
the limitations to the lentivirus is
mostly around cost the safety is pretty
good but there's always the concern
about using a viral vector and the main
reason for that safety concern is
lentivirus do random integration and so
there's the concern of what if it
integrates in the wrong spot
um there's limits on insert size as you
get bigger it gets harder there's limits
on multiplexing it just starts to having
to have multiple complexes to be able to
do that
and it's a bit challenging towards
allergenic just because you're limited
on how you can Target since it's random
incorporation if you need to do specific
things and kind of aim for a specific
clone it can be done but it's a harder
tool to be used and that's why we're
seeing more use of Gene editing
approaches sometimes in lentivirus also
but the main reason for these is it's
very efficient to Target and knock out a
gene that you want in a manner that you
want you can bring in new payloads knock
these in and that's getting very
efficient uh using aav as a donor
and of course you know there's broad IP
here and so when you're thinking about
how I'm going to do it
you have access you know that's that's a
concern when you're figuring out these
types of Therapies
so when you're using gene editing when
you're using cast 9 or other tools
there's a couple of terms that we use
all of these are going to be directly
cutting the DNA and so these are we call
them nucleases because they're going to
be making a double strand cut that
double strand cut can have a couple of
outcomes one of those outcomes is a
knockout and that's essentially when the
DNA is cut and it comes together and it
has kind of a random indel and that
indel uh disrupts the codons and causes
the gene to be interrupted and thereby
not expressed appropriately you can also
do that with a small donor that puts
like a stop coat on so you have a more
controlled outcome and then there's
something called knock in and knock-in
is where you want to open up the genome
and put something new in whether that's
a car cassette whether that's a tag like
a gfp tag you can put new DNA in there
and there it has to be very specific you
want to be able to get it in frame you
want to be able to get it at the proper
Terminus if you're tagging and so this
technique is a little bit harder and it
depends on the efficiency of the
nuclease to cut
so for cutting
the nucleases that we generally use a
thermo fissure is we have the talons and
the talons are a good tool that give you
really good specificity and cutting
efficiency I'm not going to talk further
about those today but if you are
interested in talents
um you can reach out to us and we can
talk further about it the main tools
that we use is the crispr cast 9. and we
use this as a protein occasionally as an
mRNA or as a lentiviral and the way that
the crispr cast 9 works of course is
you've got the protein and then you have
a guide RNA that you complex with it and
then this complex together is what does
the targeted cutting
so when you think through the workflow
what are you going to be doing uh the
first step is you choose kind of your
design are you going to be going which
nucleus are you going to be using
um what is your target uh and there's
many tools including tools from us that
help you design for your Target and
either make a teller and make a guide
RNA design for that and then
you can also design your experiment to
tag
um whatever you like for that and so
from this you would order your cas9
nuclease you'd order your guide rnas
you'd make your door no your donors or
use kits to be able to bring in your
donors
and then the other parts that you would
be doing as far as uh design part is do
you want to do a loss of function
Library
and so here you may be looking at say a
kinase Library you want to know if you
knocked out a kinase does it have an
effect on your model and so we also have
lentiviral libraries which has all of
the kinases with guide rnas so that you
can very efficiently in a raid format
knock them out and then grow up your
cells and see is there a phenotype uh
growth defect or anything that you can
see that indicates that kinase was
important for your disease or for the
model that you're studying we also can
make custom libraries and we also can do
as Eric was talking about custom cell
model engineering and make exactly what
you want and deliver you the cells
instead of the tools for you to make
those cells
um and along with that we have
analytical services on those libraries
or on those tools the workflow of course
you figure out what you want you order
it once you get those things with crispr
cast 9 the really nice thing about it is
it's a quite simple reaction you
essentially just take the guide RNA and
you complex it with your cas9 protein
it's almost like setting up a PCR
reaction and then you add it to your
cells and that can be with a lipid
complex like an LNP or by
electroporation
uh usually two or three days later
you're going to measure your editing and
you can do that by sequencing or there's
a t7 endoassay that we call the genomic
cleavage detection assay and you can see
if you actually cut your cells at a
decent rate and then you would screen
for the affected clones
and expand them
so pretty straightforward uh workflow
the reason that we suggest using the
protein system we actively use plasmids
we actively used mRNA but what we saw
with a protein system is the ease of use
the Simplicity of it and thereby the
effectiveness of it when you're working
with the plasmid there's a lot of steps
that have to happen from delivery
through making your mRNA transcript
complexing with your guide RNA you know
both of those have to survive in the
cell in the nuclease environment complex
to each other and then get back into the
nucleus to edit and so while the MRNA
simplifies it a bit you can see the
protein you pre-complex them together
it's all ready to go the protein
protects the guide RNA so it's much more
robust and you deliver it to the cells
the protein has a strong nuclear
localization signal so it very quickly
goes into the cells and has the effect
since you are dosing it you have the
protein exactly what you want if you
need more editing oftentimes it just
means you have a higher dose of protein
you don't get interrupted by what could
happen why didn't my plasmid Express
well you're simplifying it out and from
that we were able to rapidly optimize
this system and oftentimes get very
close to 100 editing with the protein
system without very much optimization
and so that's one of the main reasons
robustness ease of use and just you know
Simplicity of the design for this
one of the other things that we observed
when we were using this is we did
Westerns on the express protein and as
you see in the lower right
when you're using a plasmid you get you
start off with low expression but it
builds up and it stays high so three
days later you've still got high
expression of your cas9
with your mRNA system it's used and then
it kind of turns over in a couple of
cell cycles so usually three to four
days later it's pretty clear and the
same with the protein you can start with
the high dose and then that gets turned
over because you're not making any more
of it and the cells will clear it from
the system the advantage of this is that
if you're thinking about I want to be
able to cut my Target but I don't want
to cut randomly or at off Target within
the genome
the more nuclease I have just sitting
around after I've made the edit the
higher chance there is for off Target
whereas with the protein you start with
a high amount you can get the edit that
you want and then it goes away so the
off Target risk is much lower and
there's several papers that have very
clearly shown that the plasmid
expression systems have significantly
higher off Target risk even with good
guide rnas compared to the protein
system
now here's just an example of what's
going on in the cells since the cas9 has
a strong nuclear localization signal
it's got two of those
once you deliver it you can see it's
going into the cells and here's just an
example and you can see when you overlay
the cas9 and the dappy which is staining
the nucleus you can see it goes almost
exclusively into the nucleus so whatever
you're dosing is going where you need it
to be which is where the genome is
there's not much out in the cytoplasm
and so you get a good efficient delivery
and a good efficient uh editing
so when you're thinking about clinical
work you know if your disease model
you're thinking I'm going to be moving
this eventually to actual therapeutic
application one of the things that we
consider is is the tools that you're
using early on in research going to be
able to carry through with you to
commercialization because there's a lot
of things about stability about Supply
and performance that could change if you
have to change suppliers so we made the
decision to go ahead and make a GMP
version of our standard cas9 it's the
exact same construct and the only
difference is we improve the
purification concentration and the scale
of this so that we would be able to
potentially Supply this towards any
therapeutic application what that really
means is you're able to make instead of
you know micrograms or migs of this
we're making grams quantity lots of this
and highly pure under controlled
manufacturing processes this is also
done in aseptic manufacturing which I'll
talk about in a bit and extensively
safely safety tested lots of qcs make
sure there's no contaminants no
carryovers and safe for use in a
therapeutic application
CTS this is our Cell Therapy Systems
this is what we use to mean GMP and it's
essentially the regulations that we're
following as well as the testing and
documentation rigor that goes through
anything that's going to potentially be
used in an FDA approved application
so
the process itself is fully controlled
and fully contained from fermentation
all the way through violin these are in
single-use uh sterile
um you're never pouring something from
one thing to another it's all piped
through fused tubing and so the risk of
environmental contamination is
pretty much eliminated and the risk of
cross-contamination since this is all
single use is also pretty much
eliminated and so that along with very
stringent testing helps make sure that
we have a very you know quality product
so the qcs that we use going to run
through these uh there's several of them
that you see here and they're grouped up
into kind of three main uh areas one of
them is product related impurities so is
the final purified product what we say
it is and so we have uh Purity we check
for Aggregates we run this by Page in
hplc to confirm that this is a very pure
protein
the next part is
process related impurities is there any
carryover nucleases from the E coli that
this was made in is there any carryover
E coli proteins or environmental
proteins or DNA that have been
introduced to the process
endotoxin sterility testing and
mycoplasma testing and so we make sure
that this isn't going to cause problems
Downstream and then finally
characterization just standard make sure
the concentration is what we say it is
because as I'm going to talk about
further since you can dose the protein
making sure that you have consistent
concentration is important to make sure
that you have consistent editing
so
how do we do this at scale
um what are we looking for for
qualification of the cas9 protein we do
three tests and one of those is an in
vitro assay that just confirms that the
protein is cutting another is an in Vivo
testing in T cells this is a primary T
cells this is what you know kind of a
cell model that is is commonly being
used now so we want to make sure that
the protein we're making is reproducibly
performing in what people are going to
be using it for and then we also check
this in multiple systems neon is a small
scale electric creation does like 10 to
100 microliters and the Xenon system is
a as a therapeutic rate which can do you
know Mills of cells at a time billions
of cells
so first of all this in vitro cutting
assay it's just like a restriction essay
where you give it a template and you see
can I cut it we do this across the
titration of protein concentrations to
get a dose curve the reason this is
important is that if you use too much
cas9 you're going to get a plateau and
you wouldn't be able to see if you've
lost half your activity if you're well
into your Plateau so when you're
checking activity you want to make sure
you're in the linear area and see am I
cutting and am I cutting reproducibly
across Lots or across variants and so
here you can see the research grade is
performing the same as the GMP grade in
this cutting assay
uh we use this assay as we're measuring
performance as we go through uh testing
things like freeze thaw can you freeze
and thaw these we generally for like a
research use you're commonly using the
same vial over and over again and you
can see five free thaws doesn't really
cause any difference compared to the
normal for therapeutic generally you're
not going to be opening and shutting it
just because once you open it you have
the risk of contamination from your
environment
um but if you needed to or if you needed
to open it and re-aliquot it you can
again see that there's really no effect
from uh at least five free sauce
there's also uh how stable is the
protein complex and so we made these we
complexed them with the guide RNA and
then we left them out on the bench uh
from uh 10 minutes to 16 hours and then
check their activity and what was
interesting is that the rmp complex is
quite stable we don't see any loss of
activity uh even after long exposures at
room temperature
so we explored that a bit further and
what you're seeing on the left is cell
viability this is just showing that
leaving it out on the bench didn't
change or cause any toxicity and then on
the right is cutting activity and again
you can see that even out to a month
either stored in a fridge at four
degrees or on the bench at room
temperature and root temperature for Us
is around 20 degrees
you didn't see any significant loss of
activity which is nice uh if you're
doing lots of bench top activities like
screens I don't really see a therapeutic
need for this because most you know the
recommendation is use it formulate it
and use it but it does start opening up
options where you can have a stable rmp
complex that could be considered as a
starting point
the next thing that we looked at was uh
editing efficiencies and T cells and
here again viability stayed High across
multiple targets and you can see we
tried some hard targets as well as
targets that seem to perform well and
both the REO and CTS performed equally
well across multiple targets so whatever
you're using with our REO enzyme when
you switch over to the CTS you can
expect the same performance there
and then we compared it to other
suppliers of GMP cast 9. and here
generally if you use a lot of protein
you're going to see the same effect but
on some of these harder targets we did
see a difference and then when we do the
titration on the right you can see
what's going on there and essentially
what you see is R is in the dark blue is
effective at a lower dose which means
that either the specific activity of the
cast iron we're producing is better or
the NLS uh the nuclear localization and
the efficiency of getting to the Target
is improved and over these targets you
can see in each of these cases you've
got a more robust robust enzyme with the
Therma Fisher one and this comes into
effect when you're talking about you
know full-scale costs and all that
because what you want to be targeting is
you don't want to be right on a plateau
where dosing considerations might cause
significant differences you want to be
to the left of the plateau so you get a
more robust dose expense and you can see
you're going to use twice as much of the
competitor enzyme to be able to get that
same same
Effectiveness profile potentially
the next part is just lots a lot
performance we made three manufacturing
lots of these at full scale and you can
see that all three lots across these
dilution series and multiple targets
they perform just about the same so
you're going to get it's a really well
controlled process you're going to get
the same enzyme across uh
overtime and then finally how does this
work for knocking efficiency
again cell viability on the left no
problems with our platform and then on
the right what you're looking at is the
total editing with the numbers so this
is both knock in and indel and then the
light blue is the indel of a small
single strand donor so this is the
insertion of six bases and you can see
that single strand donors are very
effective in this system this is going
to vary depending on your target you see
this pd1 we could see very little indel
and it would look almost all HDR some
targets it's the other way you see very
little HDR and you see very high indel
and it depends on the sequence that
you're cutting at so this will vary but
you can see that for small donors this
system can be very effective and then
also wanted to show a large donor a car
T which is around two to three KB and
here what we're showing is first you're
looking at the T cells in flow in the
upper left and what you can see here is
that these cells without any cas9 or any
donor the donors delivered by aav
it's all pretty much no car car would be
at the top and the T Cell receptor 91
percent
once you add the cas9 you can see very
effective knockout of the T Cell
receptor and 96 percent of the cells now
have no expression of the T Cell
receptor and the lower left when you add
just aav again no cas9 you again see the
aav is very ineffective you don't see
any movement to the top boxes
but once you combine all of this
together the cas9 and the aav donor this
is by electroporation again inactivated
T cells you see a very strong shift from
the lower right which is where you're
starting to the upper left almost 90
percent of your cells have a knockout of
the T Cell receptor and a knock-in of
your car donor and when you use this in
a killing assay you can see that these T
cells are very well targeted against a
cd19 cells and kill that very
effectively compared to the unedited
cells
uh when you look at these cells also for
you know did we mess up the cells did we
exhaust them through the process what
you're looking here is the bottom panel
is the unedited cells so none of these
have the car complex which is the upper
box
and then you're comparing essentially
the population across these uh to the
top population you can see it's almost
identical the only difference is that uh
the edited cells have the car uh
inserted in that but for exhaustion and
from memory and activation they're
identical to the cells that we started
with so the process is effective and
you're not hurting yourselves in a
manner that we can see
we also wanted to do a full kind of
therapeutic workflow and here we're
going to be starting with the cells
processing them and preparing them for
uh
at a scale that you would be able to use
for therapeutic and so what that means
is concentration of the cells through a
instrument called the Rota using Dyna
beads to be able to pull out the CD3
cd28 population
adding that to the cas9 and donor and
guide RNA together and using this
large-scale Xenon device which can be
used for electrolating billions of cells
and then expanding these out in our
recommended media the optimizer T Cell
expansion media and then finally
analysis at the end just a quick comment
on the Xenon this is a new instrument
that we have that can do this large
scale as a single shot or a continual
multi-shot approach to be able to deal
with tens of millions to billions of
cells
fully tracking software on it and
supporting reagents are available if
you're ready to move to that scale
um the setup itself we started off with
5 times 10 to the seventh million cells
uh and then used the noted amounts of
the cas9 guide RNA and donor DNA and we
deliver this by electropriation either
with the neon system or the Xenon system
and these recommended voltages this is
what we are using
and what you can see here is we get
really good editing uh in this case uh
one comment that I forgot to make sorry
is this is a uh non-viral donor we're
not using aav donor anymore we're using
Straight just double strand DNA
linearized donor now and so what you can
see again is The Knockout is 94 to 97 of
the cells are edited and of that
population uh in the two runs with two
different donors uh 48 to 68 or to 60 of
the cells have the donor knocked in in a
non-viral way when we check this with a
killing assay again we see very
effective killing for both donors
compared to the unedited controls so
both the smaller scale research use
application as well as the large scale
application
um therapeutic scale works very well so
that in summary you know what we're
talking about here is to use high
quality enzymes Thermo Fisher is a very
good supplier of these will stand behind
the performance and the ability to
supply these and we have full workflow
solutions from enzymes media and
instruments to be able to help work
through this
so that's the first part of this talk
um the second part that I wanted to go
into pretty quickly is just to talk
about kind of the Next Generation
concerns and what you hear about a lot
with Gene editing is this concern about
off Target
what's happening is my cas9 cutting
where I don't want it to do essentially
will cast 9 cause a problem in this
therapy
um
so let me go through
first you know when does off Target
matter
what's the risk you know what are you
doing if you're doing research use the
risk is very much control you're not
going to hurt anybody and by using
replicates you can very much control for
the risk against the risk of off Target
however if you're doing therapeutic you
really have to know what's happening and
can this cut elsewhere and especially
you know when this is cutting where is
it cutting is the off Target in you know
non-coding regions of the gene might not
be that much of a risk is it in a
oncogene yeah that's going to be a high
risk so understanding that profile is
very important
uh and then the types of off Target are
unwanted editing uh are the standard off
Target when we talk about off Target
usually this just means that the guide
RNA that there that it cuts at a
sequence that's very similar to the
guide RNA a few bases up to generally
you're seeing three to four bases uh
potential similarity that it might cut
out at different locations another thing
is when you're doing Multiplex say I'm
cutting at two different targets uh
since you're making double strand breaks
there's the risk that they recombine
across the chromosomes so you get these
types of Junctions that weren't
expecting this is low but this
definitely can happen and is seen when
you do Multiplex so if you're knocking
out track and you're also knocking out a
couple of other T-cell genes to help
make your treatment better this is a
risk especially if you're trying to do
it all in one shot
another is if you're using a donor is
does the donor go where you want it to
go sometimes it's going to go uh at this
at where you're targeted and you made
your cut but it potentially can also go
at these off targets or just in fragile
sites of the genome so understanding
where it is and then finally
um a more this risk is something that's
becoming more and more apparent more
recently is the idea of large deletions
at the side of the cut so you're making
a cut and instead of getting these small
indels you're getting large deletions
thousands of bases and when you're
getting thousands of basis deletions you
start maybe knocking out nearby genes
and in some cases you can knock out the
whole
distal end of the chromosome arm and so
being able to measure this or check for
these things as you're figuring out your
strategy are important
I'm going to focus on the first one and
for that
um
the main question is again around how do
you measure this the way that we measure
this is through sequencing and
sequencing we use an approach called
techseek which is very similar to guide
seek to be able to discover what's going
on and then this is followed up with
targeted sequencing to be able to see if
those areas that were discovered with
techseek are actually happening in your
cells
so techseek the idea is you cut your
genome and when you're cutting it you
also are delivering a small double
strand donor tag and this sequence is
able to be integrated at your break and
then you can use this after you've
shared the DNA and and repaired it to be
able to have an anchor to sequence out
of to be able to see what is the Border
regions and then from that you can
identify chromosomal areas that you may
be having an off Target happening and
when you get these chromosomal areas you
can then design PCR primers for each one
of these and then do the experiment
again without the double strand tag and
see do you see anything happening there
the reason why you need to do both is
guide seek is Discovery but it's not
quantitative sometimes you're going to
get high reads here that you never see
in your cells when you're doing this one
the tab seek or the targeted amplicon
this is much more quantitative you can
see how many cells are actually being
edited at the off Target locations and
these have both been published as has
the guide sync
um off Target generally is going to has
rules it's generally small variations to
your guide sequence it's most amendable
to the five Prime end this is the most
flexibility uh and then there's also the
requirement for the Pam if you don't
have your Pan the risk of off Target is
quite low and so you can see all of
these off targets pretty much have the
expected Pam but cas9 can also cut at an
N AG or an NGA cam sometimes
and then there's also the idea of bulges
where it's the sequence with an extra
base or a deleted base so very similar
um but another base in there that can
cause this
so when you're looking at these things
again the question is where are they
cutting are they cutting in energetic
regions less risk regulatory reasons
more risk introns you know maybe exons
definitely higher risk and oncogenes the
highest so identifying where they are is
important to your risk profile and then
finally as you look at all these things
you can use these profile tools to be
able to understand what's happened in
your cells of Interest
uh we have a design tool called true
design that allows you to
design your guide RNA experiment as well
as gives you a score about what your off
Target risk is
um off Target again is mostly based off
of uniqueness and this is something that
is helpful if you have something with a
high score you generally have a low risk
if you have a very low score you're in
trouble
so the main strategies to minimize this
is use cas9 as a protein format as said
that minimizes your risk that it's going
to hang around long term like plasma
does use a high scoring guide RNA
and then finally we also have high
fidelity cast nines and High Fidelity
cas9s minimize the off Target risk
because they're more specific however
they're not quite as active as the
standard wild type so we recommend using
a wild type unless you know you have a
guide RNA that has a strong off Target
right
so
skip this
um the idea of specificity is
you want to pick guide rnas with a high
score and so we did this across scores
from 50 up to 93 and when we did deep
sequencing for these for off Target
these ones with high scores only had one
noticeable off Target when we dug into
that deeper we noticed all of these ones
that did have an off Target that off
Target was a bulge sequence which our
algorithm didn't look for so again if
you use a high scoring guide RNA the
risk of off Target is quite low so
that's the first recommendation but
sometimes you don't have a high scoring
guide RNA available
when we looked at the available High
Fidelity so-called High Fidelity cas9s
one of the obvious things that came out
is compared to Wild type cast9 the
activity dropped off significantly with
the specificity so the ones with really
high specificity had really poor cutting
activity so we wanted to
identify a cas9 that has high activity
and high specificity so our screening
efforts there led to the one that we use
and so what I'm showing you here is
the guide seek the tag seek results and
you can see when you start with wild
type this is a not that good of a guide
RNA there's all of these targets that
can happen
when we checked a competitor available
High Fidelity you can see that the off
targets went down significantly so the
risk is reduced
but when we checked ours you could see
that a lot of these
targets were completely removed and this
again is one with a guide RNA that is a
really poor performing guide RNA the
heck 4 guide RNA that's used in several
of the papers so the risk and the number
of events can be reduced significantly
with our new Hi-Fi cas9 from Thermo
Fisher when you look at this when you're
designing out an experiment again if you
look at the other supplier compared to
Wild type compared to our true cut
if you do multiple guides you can often
find ones that are quite unique and have
no off-target risk but sometimes again
those those don't cut where you need to
so with the wild type you can see I've
only got nine of my guides are going to
be able to work with a competitor I've
got 11 that I've been able to eliminate
the off Target and with ours you're
getting 14 you're getting really good
clearance and the ones that are left are
reduced in Risk so this is the idea that
when you have to use a certain guide
just because it's cutting very
effectively but you have enough Target
risk that's when you consider hifis to
be able to help eliminate that risk and
potentially push that off Target out of
the picture
so again
um better cutting activity or not better
cutting activity but lower off Target
activity
across these and then for cutting
activity across all of these different
targets what we saw is you do have a
trade-off high fives aren't as active as
wild type so sometimes you don't have
quite as much cutting activity and what
this means sometimes is you have to use
a higher dose to be able to get to the
same cutting as you get starting off
with the wild type
so in summary uh use we have CTS to cut
cas9 if you're looking towards a
therapeutic application we have the true
cut Hi-Fi cast 9 if you need to minimize
your off Target risk and then we also
have several off-target services that
this Tech seek approach can be done as a
service on whatever targets you're
interested in so thank you for your time
and uh let me know if you have any
questions
thank you Jason
and to both speakers for sharing your
expert insights on these topics
we will now start the Q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now clicking on
the ask question box located on the far
left of your screen we will do our best
to address as many questions as possible
in the event that we're unable to do so
Representatives representatives from
Thermo Fisher Scientific will reach out
via email with an answer
also please stay with us until the end
of the webinar to participate in a
survey
and stand a chance to win an exclusive
getco 60th birthday brick set
all right it looks like we have quite a
few questions coming in already perhaps
we can get started with questions for
Eric
first question is
how do you choose your cas9 nucleus
reagent
oh that's a very good question it really
depends on on the application that
you're working on and and also the
ability to deliver payloads to your
cells I would say that you know if you
can easily deliver protein complexes
either using liposuction or elect
operation to your cells I would highly
recommend to going the protein route
um you know we have a number of
different proteins there a wild type
version a high fidelity one as well as a
Cell Therapy Systems grade one so a lot
of different options there
um that said you know in certain cases
mRNA or plasmids may be more useful for
example
um for in Vivo editing a mRNA it is much
easier to deliver than a protein right
now
um so you know something to keep in mind
but for the player potent stem cell
workflow I definitely recommend the the
protein
okay great thank you for your next
question what cas9 form and delivery
method yields most efficient genome
editing and pluripotent stem cells
right so it kind of ties in into what I
just mentioned
um but but I think you know again for
for ipsc the cas9 protein pre-complex
with the guide RNA will will yield the
highest editing efficiencies in in the
ipsc and as I had shown during the
presentation
both delivered with the lipofectamine
stem as well as neon electroporator
gives you a good editing efficiencies
but if you're really going for the
highest possible editing efficiency I
recommend that you deliver that cas9
protein guide RNA complex with the neon
electroperator because the as I had
shown the efficiency is significantly
higher
okay thank you and we've got one more
question here for you why is cloning of
edited stem cells needed
right so in when you're thinking about a
disease model
um you know ideally you want every
single cell in your culture to have the
mutation or the genome edited
portion in in your culture right and so
get getting a hundred percent editing
efficiency especially when we're talking
about snip changes is pretty much
impossible in ipsc right now with the
tools available
so the easiest way to get around that
and to have a culture with 100 of the
cells having the
um
genome edit of choice you know cloning
is the easiest way to do that um and and
as I mentioned you know it's fairly easy
to do that in ipsc right now I mean the
caveat there is that you have to use the
reagents that are optimized for it so um
you know if you use laminin 521 which is
a matrix that's been
specifically developed for single cell
survival of ipsc as well as using a stem
Flex medium which
um supports single cell survival as well
you can be very successful in isolating
ipsc clones
well now proceed with questions for
Jason
all right Jason your first question is
how do I choose between a Hi-Fi cas9 and
wild type cas9
so what I'm looking at that there's
there's kind of two views the first is
just Effectiveness if you need really
the best cutting oftentimes the wild
type cast 9 does cut the best as we
talked about earlier
um if you've got a persistent off Target
that this is a guide that is performing
really well you're getting good
um donor delivery at that location but
there is a known
um off Target that you need to get rid
of then oftentimes we'll see how well
the Hi-Fi Compares in many of the
targets that we checked HiFi did perform
equally to Wild type there's just some
of them that it did not so there is that
performance consideration
some Labs though they use Hi-Fi across
the board because they want to minimize
off-target risk in everything so they've
made the decision to just optimize along
the lines of a Hi-Fi reagent and not use
wild type at all so it's kind of there's
different views with that I use both
enzymes but I think either way is
appropriate
our next question are there ways to
minimize double strand break induced
deletions
so when we were talking about what can
happen when you do an edit uh there is
that risk that whenever you make a
double strand break there is the
potential for large deletions or loss of
the chromosome arm
uh
this is something that the field is
actively looking at and I'm not aware of
a way to reduce that risk with a
nuclease that makes a double strand
break so this is more of something to be
checking for and determining if it
matters for you there are alternative
Technologies you may have heard of
things like base editor or prime editing
and these are working off of the idea
that you're nicking instead of making a
double strand break to try and minimize
that type of outcome
okay thank you and one other question
here for you can you do multiple edits
at the same time and how many
so we you can
um the neat thing about the protein
complex is you can uh assemble multiple
rnps and then put them all together you
can even just add the guide rnas as a
pool into your protein and they'll
they'll self-assemble
um so we've done up to four at the same
time and the neat thing that you see
there is that whether you deliver them
individually or in Multiplex you get the
same efficiency we don't see any loss of
activity by doing Multiplex however the
risk is that when you do Multiplex you
are making two cuts at known areas in
the genome and you do have a risk of
them recombining and so there's some
strategies to try and minimize that risk
where you essentially do sequential
cutting you'll cut with the one and then
once the cells have recovered you'll
dose them again with cas9 and cut with
the other this again works well with a
protein because the protein turns over
rapidly you would not be able to do with
this with the plasmids because the
plasmid persists for days to weeks and
so that's it it's doable
well thank you Jason for your answers to
these questions
this wraps up our gibco galaxy tour
webinar today I would like to thank Eric
and Jason for sharing their knowledge
and experiences which I am sure will be
helpful to researchers working in the
genome editing field
a big thank you to our audience for
joining us today and for submitting
interesting questions for those
questions that we were unable to answer
today we will follow up
um with an answer via email
we hope all of you have gained more
knowledge today that will help to
enhance your lab skills we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational
webcasts before we go I'd like to ask
everyone to take our survey at the end
of the webinar to tell us your feedback
when you complete the survey you'll be
entered to a drawing to win an exclusive
gibco 60th birthday brick set this
webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
we hope to see you again for our get go
Galaxy tour webinar next year thank you
and goodbye for now